beamen funktioniert in wien ist es jetzt
zum ersten mal gelungen mehrere
lichtteilchen zu beamen die die
silhouette einer katze mit einem
lichtstrahl projizierten der diese
silhouette nie getroffen hatte
die quantenphysik lässt grüßen jetzt
klick zum science fiction
quantenphysik ist schon ein bisschen
verrückt und vor allem lässt sie uns an
der realität zweifeln denn je nachdem
was wir beobachten verändern die
elementarteilchen ihre eigenschaften
hierbei clixoom haben wir es schon mal
gezeigt lichtteilchen photonen können
sich wie teilchen wie ein strahl
verhalten oder wie eine welle
normalerweise erzeugt ein lichtstrahl
der auf eine schablone trifft schatten
beobachte ich jedoch nicht den
strahlengang dann verhält er sich
vollkommen anders und erzeugt
interferenzen wie eine welle
zudem funktioniert kranken physik mit
wahrscheinlichkeiten ereignisse treten
erst durch die beobachtung ein
berühmtestes beispiel schrödingers katze
in dem gedankenexperimente sitzt eine
katze in einen geschlossenen kasten
die katze wird mit einem gift getötet
dessen kabel durch ein geigerzähler
ausgelöst wird der wiederum durch den
zerfall eines atomkerns angeregt wird
dieser zerfall findet aber nur mit einer
wahrscheinlichkeit stadt ist der kasten
also geschlossen ist die katze also nur
mit einer wahrscheinlichkeit tot erst
und das ist tatsächlich so nehmen wir
die katze beobachten also die kiste
öffnen entscheidet sich ob die katze
lebt oder tot ist davor ist sie weder
tot noch lebendig verrückt jetzt haben
wissenschaftler mit der quantenphysik
etwas komplett verrückt es geschafft ein
lichtstrahl projiziert ein bild das er
nie gesehen hat die lösung ist die
verschränkung von teilchen es können
nämlich teilchen erzeugt werden
die miteinander verbunden sind geschieht
mit dem ein teilchen etwas dann passiert
es auch dem anderen teilchen auch wenn
er sich am anderen ende des universums
befindet diesen effekt haben sich
quantenphysiker jetzt zunutze gemacht
mit einer komplizierten apparatur haben
sie verschränkte teilchen erzeugt
genauer lichtteilchen photonen
sie leiteten einen lichtstrahl durch ein
kristall dass daraus einen infraroten
und einen roten lichtstrahl machte die
photonen der beiden strahlen waren
verschränkt wichtig war jetzt dass die
strahlen gänge der strahlen nicht
beobachtet werden konnten
damit sie sich wie wellen verhalten
genau wie bei unserem experiment und
jetzt passierte das sensationelle
während der infrarote strahlung oder
eben genau nicht strahl sondern die
infrarote welle die schablone der katze
zeigte machte der rote strahlt etwas
ganz und gar verblüffendes er
projizierte eine rote katze obwohl
dieser strahl beziehungsweise diese
welle die schablone der katze nie
gesehen hatte
die teilchen die photonen waren
tatsächlich verschränkt damit wurde
nicht nur ein beeindruckender beweis für
die quantentheorie erbracht sondern auch
die grundlage für eine neue abbildung
technik gelegt jetzt können bilder von
frequenzbereichen die eigentlich nicht
sichtbar sind mit verschränkten
lichtstrahlen mit unterschiedlichen
frequenzen fotografiert werden
das wird ziemlich spannend was wäre da
noch so zu sehen bekommen und ich bin
mal sehr gespannt ob dieses experiment
je mit anderen teilchen wie elektronen
protonen oder neutronen gelingt dann
wird beamon tatsächlich realität ein
anderes sehr spannendes
gedankenexperiment habe ich hier
angestellt
es gibt keine wirklichkeit leben wir in
einem multiversum dafür im hier klicken
täglich wissenschafts news gibt es
hierfür smartphone in der app einfach
draufklicken alle links auch in der
video beschreibung und was meint ihr
wird beamon realität diskutiert es in
den kommentaren und solange ich noch
niemand weg gewählt hat bis dann bleibt
dran
euro